asking you or some people are inquiring
about you running for a prime minister
in canada
and like your reaction was really
specific you're like
i thought about doing it but it would
take me too long to learn about the
power grid
so i can't do it and i was just like
what
i thought it was a really cool answer
because most people just go yeah i'll
run for president and i'll hire some
[ __ ] to figure out the [ __ ] power
grid
right well maybe that's a better answer
you know but i'm
i'm it's a very complicated job running
a country
and i suspect you should prepare for it
by knowing some things about how to do
it and
um you know that hasn't been my
preparation except perhaps on the
psychological front so
and i'm also more interested in
continuing to do what i'm doing which
at least in principle is to provide some
useful psychological guidance for as
many people as possible
and to participate in the constant
dialogue about where the culture's
heading and why
so i don't know i just thought that
answer was so you
i thought the answer was reflective of
your identity it was like
i'm not the right person for this job in
order for me to do it it would take too
much time away from the things that i
enjoy
so perhaps the things that i'm better at
or i mean i've made that decision
continually throughout my life because
i've i've
contemplated a political career multiple
times but when when push came to shove i
always decided to keep doing what i was
doing which was
philosophical investigation and
scientific investigation i suppose as
well as
my practice as a professor and as a
clinician
just seemed the better fit for me
temperamentally do you
feel like like
do you sometimes feel like you're like a
seven foot guy
with amazing athleticism that can shoot
a basketball like you're just so good at
it
that you should do it but maybe it's not
the thing that you want to do
no i think it's been the thing i think i
was fortunate that i got to do the thing
that i wanted to do
i mean i really loved my my job as a
professor and as a
clinician it was extremely rewarding in
pretty much every possible way
i love doing the scientific research
and answering questions that way i liked
engaging with my competent colleagues i
liked my graduate students i
really enjoyed teaching undergraduates i
liked my clinical practice and i had a
very very wide range of clients ranging
from people who were
barely hanging on to the edge of the
world to people who were unbelievably
competent and accomplished
and so i got to see a huge range of
people's lives and
and that was extremely exciting and i
ran a couple of businesses
more or less on the side or was involved
in their running and so
that was all extremely good i've been
exceptionally fortunate in that
and then i've been on a tremendous
adventure for the last five years as
well
even though it's been it's torn me apart
in some ways it certainly hasn't been
boring
it's been unbelievably exciting yeah
incredibly
too exciting i would say pretty much all
the time
yeah yeah the curse of an interesting
life i suppose
yes yes yes um yeah i don't know it's
just it's just
it's really refreshing to hear you
say yeah to hear you say that you
struggle with identity
that is that is refreshing because it
seems from the outside that you have it
figured out and uh
yeah i can imagine somebody looking
right now going like oh man
i don't know what the hell i want to do
or maybe i do know what i want to do but
i don't know who i am and i'm being
swayed and pulled all these different
directions and then to hear someone that
they really
admire and look up to is also feeling
those things is very refreshing man i
i don't know i yeah it's kind of like i
think it's even ballsy to say
i think a lot of people in your position
would be like no i got it keep buying
the books
yeah well i guess i'm still trying to
figure it out and maybe that's what
makes the books
useful to people too is that i mean they
are my constant attempt
not so much to say what i know to be
true you know and shake my fist at them
and say you better believe this but to
walk through the process of trying to
figure something out which i'm
continually doing
so um you know there's been a lot of
illness in my family as of late too and
that tends to throw you for a loop
so i think all of us all of my family is
still recovering from that
and so that also puts a knot in the tail
of your identity
so to speak why is that
well because it knocks you out of your
routine i mean
i spent much of 2020
in hospitals and and 2019 as well i
spent 2019 in the hospital with my
daughter and my wife and then i spent
most much of 2020 in the hospital with
me so
you know that knocks you out of your
daily routine in a major way and
i mean all three of us had very silly
had very serious illnesses
and so and well that that that
that's a blow to the side of your head
when that happens when you think you're
close your partner's going to die for
example that's
changes things so luckily that didn't
happen
yeah yeah thank god i think it's
i don't know i wonder my i have a buddy
of mine named
little duval who's a comedian he's also
a
mentor i guess of mine he just has this
amazing understanding of life has like
no formal
background education or anything he
literally has just learned all these
things from observation
and uh he kept saying something to me
and i'm sure it's in a lot of books and
stuff like that but it's something i
always
like think about and he goes um
it's all about perspective man and he'll
like say very few words he won't like
explain much to me he'll just like say a
few words and then just kind of like
move on or just like hang up the phone
and uh and and he's like it's all about
perspective man and uh
he had a a close friend of his uh of his
die
and um of of cancer and they they knew
he had cancer for
i think it was like two years he was
supposed to have like two months and
then it ended up going for like two
years
and um he's like yeah man it was a great
gift i go what are you talking about
like a friend of cancer he goes
yeah but like you oftentimes don't know
when someone you love a lot is gonna go
away
like we knew and we did everything that
we wanted to do
those last two years and for him to look
at like the person he loved like
getting cancer as like a gift you could
almost look oh this guy's crazy
but at the same time like life happens
he would always say this he's like life
is gonna happen
how you react to life is gonna dictate
your happiness and i know there's
certain things you just cannot be happy
about of course
but making it seem like it was a choice
was like oddly empowering and i was
always curious what you would think
about about that like
how much is it your choice how you react
to these things
well it's it's always indeterminate i
mean you know there's limit situations
where things are so intense that
your attitude is well it's very
difficult to adjust your attitude
about hunger if you're starving to death
yeah
you know i mean you can all be pushed to
the point we can be pushed past the
point
i think all of us where we can control
our reactions intent
if the pain is sufficiently intense yeah
if the situation is
is sufficiently intense but you know
when in this new book beyond order the
last chapter is
be grateful in spite of your suffering
and it's
i suppose uh discussion of the
possibility of
adopting that as a a goal a decision
to be grateful and i think that you can
make that a decision to some degree yeah
and it's a fight worth having because
it's better to be grateful
than not to be and maybe that's even
somewhat independent of your situation
i know when i was particularly ill and i
was bitter because of it
then i was worse off than when i was ill
and i wasn't bitter because of it
so and so i did what i could to adjust
my proclivity for bitterness
because it didn't seem helpful and so
you know we do have this scope of
decision making that we're always
testing out
you never it's it's a dangerous thing to
push too hard because
you know you don't want to say to
someone who's suffering from
extraordinarily painful terminal cancer
for example that if they just adjusted
their attitude everything would be okay
yeah obviously that's a little bit on
the harsh side let's say but
by the same token we do have the
capacity to change the way we look at
things and
and we do the best that we can i mean
the the the fundamental ethics i suppose
that people are
are encouraged to adopt have a fair bit
to do with decision about what attitude
you're going to take
you